[Music]
[Music]
everybody welcome back to Kali Beach
today it's time for episode 22 and in
episode 21 really works on an amazing
pool and it's definitely one of my
favorite episodes other series but it
also gave me a super big challenge to
pick up because building a pool is
something that we've kind of been
planning to do since the beginning of
the series but there are all kinds of
difficult things that are parts of
building a pool and one of those was
water slides and in general there is
something which has rarely been tried
before in planet coaster and it's what
I'm going to be trying to do in this
episode now of course I'm not alone as
always we have the amazing reliever and
Camille live right here in the studio
Rudy how are you doing
hey there I'm we're good today actually
and has a lovely day in Berlin so
fastest open weather my phone course you
might be a little bit sorry for that but
the part number I'm feeling good so what
about you
all right I am hmm I might be able to
tell nothing kind of tired it's been
like one of those long weeks where I've
just had like a little bit not enough
sleep every day where it just starts
hitting you and Friday but we're
recording this on the Friday by the way
which is slightly unusual compared to a
usual Wednesday but they all get out on
time but anyway that was way too long
story I'm fine thanks it's it's one of
the things that was really difficult
though about this episode was that I
tried to sort of squish all of them
making of this episode in between all of
the the q three hours then I had sort of
scattered throughout this week but the
entire episode just turned into making
water slides and this
is actually no joke I I took me like
over for hours actually built these
water sights the way I did it as you am
probably seeing at the moment is very
modular
maybe you'll know that the real that the
the way that real water slides are built
is really in these modular kind of
pieces right where you've got these
three series of tubes that are kind of
like that they're just separate small
pieces of the tubes and they're all put
together at the at the spot where
they're going to be built with these
flanges and I wanted actually put
together the modular pieces that I
wanted to build the slide out of in a
similar way as you would in real life so
with all the flanges and the separate
parts kind of connecting in that sense
now pretty cool and I think I'm also
thankful that you do it in a let's say
on this modular basis because then we we
actually hit the point where in real
life you would have those little bumps
you know in between of the connection
points of the water flight and if the
water higher a little bit of water yeah
oh my god they're absolutely immersed I
don't think I've taught this but I'm
trying to compile a list the first world
problems and that is high of the list
when you've got these water slides
especially the faster they are and the
flanges that connect the different tubes
are super rough yes
that's terrible I have to say I have to
say I mean you should know about this I
guess living in the Netherlands I've
seen a plenty of times to do Newell is
it I don't know if I spelled it
correctly oh yeah but it's pronounced
Donal but yeah I go okay yeah with this
fancy water park there it's kind of you
know the park where we went with our
football team like every year and
literally like every year being there I
just punished like for yeah just
swimming shots crazy oh that's horrible
but it's like your back must be the
worst part though like yeah yeah yeah
and I just imagine with a bunch of
fifteen to sixteen year old boys from
football team just completely
exaggerating within the tubes yeah oh
yeah I can kill that I mean to be honest
that's what that waterpark is all about
though it's like maybe had full 15 year
old boys doing things in water slides
but yeah yet I think that's a great park
somehow by the way oh I have to tell
this because it's like literally one of
them crazy things in my life because
it's like you know you get those little
bungalows where you do live in Amman and
some one of the six people living in one
bungalow has to spend an eye on the key
like he's got the one to spend your time
holding the key and don't lose it
mm-hmm and I was the one to take care of
the key and as a turn out as always for
me somehow I of course lost the key and
it was like super amazingly bad because
like it would be really expensive
because you have to pay like the entire
bungalow
let's just fill like this and then we we
went like back from the swimming pool
and I was literally I was falling into
the sand because I was like hitting a
stone and in front of me there was lying
Mikey Wow
noises and you know if there wouldn't
have been my friends with me nobody
actually would have released that even
like virtually I mean it could have been
any key but it was letting Mikey look
like what yeah that's what happened in
this park just as a side note well
that's really also how did you know it
was your key though like did you just
pick up the key and you're just like
let's try it yeah wasn't elephant number
on it okay that makes sense
yeah no that's a crazy coincidence
those are leaking unloads that could be
an idea for record beach anyway that's
probably a ridiculous idea and yeah well
for the next four hours of footage maybe
yeah oh by the way just to maybe talk a
little bit of the footage we see right
now it already turns out to be super
amazing I mean like that's the godmother
of blueprint
yeah it was ridiculous it's
I mean the way that I had to go about
doing it was very piece by piece so I
built the flanges first and the regular
sort of two then had to build all of the
pieces so we've got regular straight
piece tees going down and different
curves and then everything has to be
colored but I used the Snowman pipes as
the flange screws now just to get that
kind of texture in there but that meant
that I had to select every like recolor
above piece separately in order to
actually be able to recolor them so like
getting everything set up as in the
blueprints that I could just drag pieces
from the bill that water slides was a
major pain but in the end I'm actually
quite happy with how they turn out oh
yeah I'm also I'm already really happy
how it turns out also how are you doing
this custom support over here it's so
amazing like it really turns out to look
like a zit if it was like a real water
fly that's easy
super amazing I think I just heard
somebody introduce the cone yeah me too
who might that be oh it's a far away
person maybe maybe the person wants to
work hey maybe this rude intruder was to
introduce themselves far away yeah I
think she's spending at the bungalows of
of coverlets right now here may you hear
me now yeah better oh it's all my
headset microphone instead of my normal
microphone so that's the problem
hey turn your down a little bit because
you're very loud at the moment but fine
don't worry about it are we already
recording yeah hello guy if you see
intruder yeah lady you are still busy
building your new computer right oh stop
talking about that okay maybe those that
no it's like the worst day ever
like seriously I never had one a
stressful week and isn't that the most
Oh
they effort though like building a new
computer isn't that the best feeling
ever
yeah if it worked but it didn't I don't
have a new computer and that's the whole
problem because the the watercooler
doesn't fit the case Odom and my
boyfriend really wanted this water
cooler like we were like we don't need
it and he was like no we need it and now
everything is like a big big problem
because of that water cooler because it
doesn't fit in a cage and it doesn't fit
on the motherboard and we need to order
something from America
well not order you can get it for free
but still it's gonna take weeks no we
really want this water cooler in so I
knew inventing like I think we better
just change the water cooler and
everything will be fine because we have
everything in house right now but we
just can't make it so yeah I really had
like the most disappointing day ever it
is a little bit like on Christmas you
know if you do see already a Christmas
present lying underneath the tree and at
the 30 at 23rd of December right
something like that yeah you can't open
it out but she's so much what you open
it and it's like oh it really really
sucks yeah so I'm really depressed right
now yeah except that's not must be
terrible can't you just put up with it
though for the time being and just risk
a computer meltdown just retie but but
did cool no we need to at least connect
the water cooler with the motherboard
but we can't are you have no way yeah
wait but why do you have to connect them
I don't know
I don't know I'm not a computer geeks
but I just know that she said like it's
not going to work because I just can't
it I don't know it just didn't fit right
and you need to order something at
as a company itself you can get it for
free but it will come from America so we
might take a few weeks oh okay I'm
really bad news for koala [ __ ] as well
it is because like Maria Bravo is
crashing quality beaches crashing and
even my Wonderland was crashing two
times the last time so that's why I
didn't upload anything like the last
week because I was like okay I'm just
not gonna do this over and over again
and restart my computer over again so I
thought yes at the end of the week I
have a new computer and then I can just
go with the flow
nope I'm not gonna have it yeah I really
really take fingers crossed that you you
will find a solution this weekend I mean
I can't you just get a part of something
else like from local suppliers for for
the time being what yes we drove three
hours today - Oh Gemma NACE no it's very
long sorry I'm not gonna bore you with
that but we drove three hours to get a
new bigger case and even that didn't
work out so we got disappointment after
disappointment I said your supreme
enough so yeah I'm really weird sounds
like that it's not the problem that's
not fitting into the case it seems more
like it's not fitting to the motherboard
right yeah both first the problem was it
didn't fit in the case that we were like
okay it doesn't fit in the case so let's
try to do it some how else and we will
order a new case this week and then we
will put it over in a new case that was
the the thing we're thinking off and
then we found out we couldn't connect it
or whatever to the motherboard so now we
got two problems all because of the
water cooler it's like the smallest part
of the computer that you want to worry
least about that's patient holding of it
well if you see the water cooler it's
not
the smallest part it's a huge file
cooler I think you wanna shame if you do
have that it's like a monster
it's like seriously monster and I had I
wish I could tell you the guy's the name
I always forgot but isn't the question
there can't you just I mean I don't know
if that makes sense but can't you just
get the part you need from some local
suppliers for I don't know how much
money but like say just for the time
being I mean it wouldn't be better to
have it and instead of waiting for so
long time yeah but that's what I said my
boyfriend just really wanted this water
cooler
oh if one of these wonderful colors with
like the giant pipes and everything
whether they is a giant it's to ven's
and it is huge it's seriously huge and
never seen anything like this it's so
it's a pretty new one so that's why you
can't really order stuff to get it right
it just sucks even the cases you need to
like do most biggest cases there are to
fit it in it's great Wow it's also one
of these things with all the ridiculous
lights and everything yeah yeah I heard
like I am a woman I don't
seriously care yeah I'm already funny I
understand why your boyfriend is you
know terrible my boyfriend wasn't aware
of the lights but but the guy who was
gonna assemble the computer he was like
oh you have so many lights I know it's
so awesome and I'm like I don't freaking
care and then we got the case issue and
it was his attention was to have like a
glass wall at the same but the case was
different from the picture so we didn't
add a glass wall like yeah we don't have
let like he was like Oh disappointed
like oh my god you have so many awesome
lights in there you can't really see
them but yeah well now we need to buy a
new case so he's hoping for a close hi
you know I'm really happy that he is
hoping for Europe
she was like so excited to see oh it was
like that's such a bummer that it
doesn't have so that was like the first
disappointment the key scary he's like
[ __ ] doesn't have a glass one I was like
oh I don't care as long as it works but
yeah then the next is pregnant skating
and what story
yeah and I know and so they were
wondering how we were going to fit 20
minutes of building what you know what
minutes are you because I haven't seen
anything we're currently in 15 minutes
in and all I'm really doing in four
hours is building plastic water slides
it just takes that long I love these
things
oh well though the layouts are done by
nose oh it looks so nice but now I am
starting to wonder to kind of bring it
back on topic how are we going to
continue with qualities now that your
computer isn't alright yeah that's a
problem I haven't thought of this this
all just happened like this evening it's
Friday evening for the ones who are
listening right now it's Friday evening
you probably hear this on Saturday and I
just heard it and my boyfriend is not at
home so I can't really discuss what to
do so I have no idea I am seriously I
have no idea maybe vertiginous about
yeah I could I could that's no problem I
think maybe we should we can definitely
do this that that won't be a problem but
we could also like see what's happening
tomorrow mm-hmm yeah including for the
description and maybe we can switch who
is doing which episode whatever there's
going to be a sort of quality next week
big yeah II was going to be in it but
you know that's a worry for another day
if you have a computer that it's not
even working yet true and and I don't
even know like I don't know what's going
to happen next week maybe we can try to
fix this and then I even if I want you
try to make like a single built-in
anonymity part I could try to do that
but I don't even know if I have time if
we have the
plan to fix this next week so that could
consume some more time to do so yeah but
I think it's an important matter to to
have this one Russian game very good
course
so no thing and I just really oh wow
wait I just I just figured where you
place those slides I was wondering the
whole time we're building those ones but
it's so good - looks like - oh yeah you
can just kind of see the placement of
them yeah I kind of tried to mess around
with the sight lines and you've got like
this amazing path doing sort of this
this path like between the two swimming
pools where you've got an amazing
overview of what's behind the swimming
pools and at the moment there isn't
really anything behind the pools what I
thought like this would be a really cool
skyline is as you're approaching the the
entire swimming pool complex you see the
pool kind of in front and then you've
got also the interesting elephants on
the side and then waterslide thank our
inside do you well super amazing also
with water oh that's so cool yeah I feel
like it's actually all kind of coming
together like I really love the entire
swimming pool area around here
yeah oh this is so so looking good again
you did it again sylph jeez oh sorry I
just have to jump in it's so funny I
just saw how who puts in the VFX on the
one side and then just recognize them I
can't color it again because yeah oh
yeah that was the role of doing things
though to be honest I'm glad that I
decided to go with these little lakes
came out areas instead of building an
entire pool because it does make it a
little bit easier and it general I don't
know what it is but I just like the look
of these things I don't know nothing
really satisfying about the look of
water slides yeah I can only agree with
that same here I have no idea what it is
exactly though but there's something
maybe it's just good memories or
something like water slides are always a
good memory
yeah they say never grow old right I
think what labs are just amazing always
like I mean even the young people today
love them so it's tough yeah it's really
really looking good in Cali friends
animatics Wow
did you also because I haven't seen a
disturber digital's and made some kind
of stairs um they're gonna come although
at the moment while I'm saying this I do
have to note that we might want to keep
talking a bit beyond the time-lapse
because I had like a few hours to record
this time-lapse but as we're talking
right now I've already done a little bit
of work which meant making a staircase
up to the water slides would like a roof
over it and like an entire construction
where I know what you call it but like
one of these towers that the water
slides come out oh yeah and I hope to
build some new water slides but that's
something I'm gonna have to add in
hindsight or maybe somebody else can try
it I don't know if any of you guys are
feeling like building some water slides
oh well I've already like a chant
I'm not really sure yet what about you
Rudy
any anyone else nobody by the way I'm
sure is maybe too many same no no same I
always say that I just you watching
karelis saloon we have a towel for you
we said this and always a slide for you
and and we have a cat looks like we
thought I was nothing maybe we could end
up each with pina colada
because I do remember that when we were
here in in rainy Netherlands that he
kept sending us pictures of amazing pina
coladas on the beach
and he mentioned that again with when he
saw the picture that really posted on
Twitter seriously over your tone he was
like where's my pity colada yeah but I
have to say it lit the genitals the
generator just kept this pina colada at
the B bar with the mechanic and they
still keep being there so yeah ooh wait
what I just want to say is um yeah I
think I could spend another look onto
the pool area because I forgot a few
things I I saw so many great things in
the comment section last time mm-hmm and
I think I I must say because we we don't
mention it too often but I really really
want to thank everyone that is so
supportive to the comments like
seriously oh yeah I really really enjoy
reading all your lovely comments on
every video we pose like every week you
guys are really amazing and to be honest
we kind of depend on it as well in many
ways like a lot of the stuff that's come
back in the park or that we decided to
think of or ideas that we've drawn are
from the comment section as well so you
know get some really awesome two-way
street in that sense as well absolutely
so please keep on commenting and we
really appreciate that
everything yeah we do it's also so funny
and and we try to to respond as much as
possible and if not we I think we do
read all of them yeah we do and and just
definitely do and try to get as much in
as possible I'm also really happy to be
asked yeah cool water not only topics
ideas because I still wanted to throw
some things out there I'm not sure if
this has been pitched though but has the
idea of a lifeguard been around since
yeah I've seen it yes that's one of the
time Andrea right Ian so it's basically
about the lifeguard seat and we
definitely need some staff into the
water so we do improve yeah
so no lettuce I definitely have to keep
an eye on them yeah but I know that that
as I was finishing the last episode also
there was like
about this because I think I should keep
it away for the next episode because
that was a great idea I definitely want
to do but I think it's a good good thing
for karelis because that's something to
do in a way with pina coladas so yeah so
I think there's still so much potential
in this park yeah absolutely
we're not done no we anniver and the
good thing though is that when I'm
finished with next week's episode or
maybe you had to work before lady I
really hope so but I just can't promise
anything
yeah no you you don't have to but no
matter when but when you get the pack
bag because we left open so much for you
oh did you yes you know the park thank
you
yeah that's true we'll see about that
and then we see how it will work out and
yet oh I do have to say as a quick note
seeing that I'm in game at the moment
I'm trying to count the pieces on the
water slides and it's eleven thousand
pieces no way maybe my idea a person to
actually run this in the end
since you won a little computer in the
end it's so great for if they have a new
book you nervous yeah I think I think
one thing we have to do for the final
recording is just meet up all of our
three and just build one computer all of
our own yeah
out of all the parts in our own
computers so to have one month's the
computer to run it
oh this is actually no working but maybe
we should call it a final episode we
could come together at my computer
that's a good point somewhere on the
village dinner colonna's oh that's good
like like we do an intro on the beach
rate of Pina Colada we should ask her
Alice to come and then we're like ladies
and gentlemen please
is our final episode Cheers oh yeah
we're taping in music playing critics
ruling I can see it oh yeah okay sounds
great
speaking of credits I think we've got
about enough for today
for this episode I'm still not entirely
sure what I'm exactly going to build in
addition to what we've seen so far but
it probably won't be too much maybe a
slider to some simple stuff but that's
something that work we're going to have
to see in post since I can't edit to the
video right now but yeah good that's
been pretty much in for today so I
really want to thank you guys for being
here
rudia lady it's me yeah thank you and
you for allowing me yeah told me I was
good with my hat said I wasn't it was
fine I have to say we haven't actually
noticed we haven't actually mentioned
this in the video but we probably should
have your sound is way better than
release was at the beginning of the
video
no offense to Rudy but it was we were
starting off with his old his old
microphone and he's in Berlin and that
went well for about 2 minutes and 24
seconds and then like I don't know what
happened but it sounded like a nuclear
explosions in the middle recording okay
well I don't know that anymore to me and
it's all okay so I don't I I really
loved it how you just came in it really
sounded like you were coming from the
other side of the park just people
coming over for us
good nice walk it almost gives the
illusion as if we're actually here
physically together in we were just
having later was just bumping in from a
distance mm-hmm yeah it's waving to you
it was about to say what if we ask you
yeah okay so that's wrecked yeah yeah I
think that's it for today so um yeah
thank you guys for watching I think you
guys for staying awesome feel free to
comment whatever you want a comment
especially if it's something to do with
these 40 slides being terrible and ways
to actually improve them so that really
can take them up and make some things
better about them or if they're awesome
that's always good to hear as well and
we'll see you guys next week
in Kahala Beach bye guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]